I was Volkswagen able to pass millions  of emission tests for years if they had  disgustingly High emissions well it  turns out that clever engineering can  easily bypass exams conducted by poorly  funded regulatory bodies what Volkswagen  had done was install special emission  software onto 11 million cars around the  world this software was capable of  detecting when routine emissions exams  were being conducted and it would change  a whole bunch of variables to reduce  emissions  change things like fuel pressure  injection timing exhaust gas  recirculation and the amount of ureas  sprayed into the exhaust while this was  extremely clever all you really had to  do to find the real emissions was use  next to a testing device that wouldn't  set off Volkswagen systems but somehow  regulatory bodies had failed to do this  for six years